hi guys want to thank film courage for
doing this interview with us today
my name is Jamison LoCascio I'm a
feature film director writer and
producer hi my name is Adam embryo I'm a
producer in one of the writers of sunset
myself and my producing partner Adam
ambrosio have just completed our second
feature film both of our feature films
have distribution have name actors have
been in festivals and have won awards
we've also produced seven SAG short
films that have been all around the
country and have distribution with
DirecTV and AT&T says a little
background on us now we wanted to come
on film courage today first of all film
courage is an excellent channel it's a
great website and everything else if
you're an indie filmmaker out there and
you're just joining them for the first
time you should definitely check out
film courage these guys are great people
and they just want to help independent
filmmakers like us the thing that film
courage asked us to do today was to come
on and talk about six things we learned
while making our first feature film the
depths that we applied to our second
feature film sunset
definitely one of the first things I
would say is to trust your passion and
to choose your advisors carefully the
people that come on and help you with
the film you have to trust these people
they'll give you a lot of information
and it's it is definitely hard to find
people that know where you're at in the
space that you're in and have the right
information for you so a lot of times as
the filmmaker comes down to you to find
the research to work very hard putting
it together
so you have to sort of trust your
instincts but you have to sort of build
those instincts first and build that
knowledge yourself and you yourself may
you may be your own best advisor rather
than someone out there who's not
familiar with what you're capable of or
what you can do maybe they don't know
what you have access to and they maybe
will misguide you based on the
information that they do know and that
they that they don't know etc
if you have the option to do it on a
smaller crew I would say that's probably
the best form to do it especially if the
budget slow you you just want a couple
of good you know dedicated people who
you know you could work with and that's
all you need for sunset it was me and
Jamison and two other people on a
four-man crew and we did a full feature
and sometimes that might be the best way
depending on you know what the project
demands
know what you absolutely need to make a
film and not just something that looks
lit see or glamorous this can apply to
the camera that you're using when you're
making a film it can apply to an actor
that you're casting a lot of times it'll
seem like you're adding this this
incredible value to your movie without
you realizing that you really only need
this little thing a lot of a perfect
sample of that maybe is that we used the
we used the Blackmagic and we didn't
shoot in 4k on our first feature film we
did shooting 4k on Sunset actually on a
much lesser budget but that's an
important thing that we that we felt
sort of defined who we were and what we
were doing at the time with our first
feature film the depths even though we
had named actors we had other things
going on in there we didn't feel it was
important to shoot in 4k and we were
right about that ultimately now on
Sunset we did do it we had the ability
to do it and the situation presented
itself to us with her with our team so
we did do it that second time and it was
nice but we definitely realized that it
wasn't that critical at the time to be
that glitzy or that glamorous we just
wanted to make our movie tell our story
and sometimes you have to realize what
is best for your film and not
necessarily what other filmmakers are
doing with their movies that they may
find important may not be important at
all for what you're doing and the realm
that you're in there's a lot of it's
understandable because there's a lot of
bad information out there too so you
have to sort of go we went to the IFP
film lab we studied a lot of different
courses and film distribution and we
figured out how to do PR ourself so a
lot of that research that we learned on
our own wound up being the most valuable
stuff that we could have learned out
there
you'd like to use sag actors we find
that the saddle solo agreement is very
doable and very fair for what we need
definitely another important thing too
is when you do we actually went out we
won an award best feature film at
Manhattan Film Festival we started
winning some acting awards Michael
Rispoli and patch Dara are both
incredible actors that are established
in the industry I've had they're all
incredible bodies of work and they were
recognized each individually were
recognized for their acting work I was
recognized as the director of the Depp's
we've also started getting acting awards
on Sunset and we did win the Best
Feature I've been having Film Festival
on the depths as soon as we started
getting those awards and those accolades
we we started getting a lot more
attention from distributors and as we
were building up this package we started
getting offers and things like that the
most important thing I would say is that
when you finally do start to get those
things you've built up enough
credibility and street cred for your
movie one of the more important things
about that is that you you definitely
study those distribution deals and look
at what they're offering you remember
these people that a lot of people don't
think about it this way they say you
know we're gonna jump off the cliff now
here's the distribution deal we're done
the reality is that whoever you go into
business with as your distributor
becomes your partner and they're there
they're just as important as the DP you
hire they're just as important as the
producer you're working with they are
your team and part of your team and you
have to work with them so make sure that
those people are you know they're
vetting you so also vet them figure out
how valuable they are and what films
they've done before and everything else
and don't just sign the first
distribution deal you come to I promise
you that your movie definitely has a
value over time especially with
streaming and everything else that you
don't just have to cash in on the first
thing that you see oftentimes those
collaborations won't make or break your
movie and it's important not to throw up
your hands and just say we're done we
have distribution now
festivals are not the most important
part of the movie it really is the story
and it's it's the decisions you make it
doesn't necessarily mean that your
movies going to be successful it's a
good way to get promotion out and to get
people interested in and can possibly
invest it into going further with it but
in terms of if you looking for
distribution
you know it's you're probably not gonna
invite someone or someone's not gonna
show up and say look I just saw the
premiere of it you know I'd like to
distribute it for you it's not usually
gonna happen that way but we do
recommend doing the festivals because it
because promotion is a big key and it
also will open a little it could open
some doors you know if you if you play
your cards right with it hey guys we
want to thank film courage for
everything that they do for independent
filmmakers they've certainly helped us
in all of our travels we hope that this
interview which was an honor to do by
the way was a little helpful to you guys
as well for anybody that's out there in
the grind trying to make your films we
know it's very hard and we support and
encourage you we also encourage you to
go check out our channel on YouTube film
valor which is a more intimate look at
all the feature films and other films
and projects that we are making thank
you guys so much thanks for watching
film courage and we'll see you guys next
time